JESS PEARSON: It's nice to
see some familiar faces,
for those of you-- hi, hi Paul.
How was lunch?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Shout out.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
it's so good, Trish.
JESS PEARSON: Trish
is very hungry.
For those that don't know me,
my name is Jess [? Pearson. ?]
I'm on the sales side.
I work on the
automotive account.
Jeffrey and I actually
met at a volunteer
at Westminster Avenue
elementary school.
We were both on a
career day panel.
And he and I have been in
touch the last couple months.
And obviously he
is a fan of Google.
And the second he walked
in, I gave him a tour.
He saw the screening room
and said, oh my gosh.
Can I bring my film in?
And so he gave me the short.
It was very humble.
It's actually an Oscar-nominated
short from this past Oscar
award season.
So we're pretty excited
to have you here, Jeffrey.
And Nora is his
wife, next to him.
Nora's very involved
in the Community Garden
Project at Westminster
Avenue School.
So thank you both for having
us-- or bring-- or coming here.
Having you.
JEFFREY KAROFF: Hi.
They want to put you on camera.
AUDIENCE: I guess for
posterity, my first question
is where did you find this guy?
I also really liked the
shot at the end, where
you have him start digging
his second magnum opus,
and you just zoom out.
And how far was the
camera from that,
and did you have to do a
couple tries to get that right?
JEFFREY KAROFF:
The first question
about where did I find him,
we have a house in New Mexico.
And I met in a small
town called Dixon.
And I met Ra when we first
started going to this house.
And I met him.
I met Shel and Liz first.
Nora and I were at
the pancake breakfast,
which was a fundraiser
for the volunteer fire
department, that kind of town.
And met Shel and
Liz, and they said
we're having a cave
dug on our property.
Are you interested in seeing it?
So that's an invitation
you don't turn down.
And it took me, after
seeing that cave--
that shot in the movie where
they come around the corner
is the experience that we had
first seeing that cave, which
was that, oh my
God, what is this?
Never seen anything like it.
I knew it was something
that was film-worthy,
but it took me many
years to figure out
a way into the story of it.
So I actually didn't start
the film till almost 10 years
after I met him.
So all of the creation
of Liz and Shel's caves
that you see in this is actually
he's working on another cave,
but we used the footage for it.
As for the last shot,
I had had that shot
in mind for a very
long time, not knowing
that I was going in
the film with it.
But I liked the idea
of man in landscape,
and it really worked well
for the theme of the film.
And I tried to shoot it with a
balloon, a GoPro on a balloon.
That was a total disaster.
I tried to shoot it with a
mini helicopter from a crew
that I found locally.
And the crew members
were all stoned,
and we did a day of shooting
and we got not a single shot
in the entire day.
So I had the one
shot of him starting.
I was so thrilled to
be there on the day
that he was actually
starting a cave,
because all those
years had passed,
and I was never in New Mexico
when he started a project.
And I was there on the day.
And I have a shot.
It was on a tripod.
And he started the cave.
And originally, my first cut, I
ended the film with that shot.
And then I was
looking at it one day
and I thought,
oh, wait a second.
Everything around
him is not moving.
And I sent a cameraman
back to that spot.
It was exactly two years
later to the month.
And I said, at 3:30, can I have
the metadata from the shot?
So I said at 3:30
in the afternoon,
stand on the hill
opposite where we were.
Point the camera, your still
camera, at the cave opening.
And do 10 shots of
different sizes,
zooming backwards without
changing the pan or the tilt.
And a compositor put
the motion frame inside
of the still frames
and pulled back.
So it's all done in post.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JESS PEARSON: Can
I use your mic?
JEFFREY KAROFF: OK.
JESS PEARSON: So I
know when we met,
you and I were on the panel.
And you had mentioned that
you direct commercials.
And I think you work with a
lot of automotive clients.
Is this your first
film that you directed?
And it almost seems like this
became your passion project
as well.
So not a question, but
just more of a comment.
JEFFREY KAROFF: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
This is my first film, yes.
Although I've done a
lot of documentaries
in the context of
fundraising films
for philanthropic
organizations and nonprofits,
so I was pretty familiar
with the form of it.
No more questions?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: What are
you working on now?
JEFFREY KAROFF: I'm
actually gone back
to my day job of
making money, the one
that-- so I'm
shooting commercials.
The one thing though
that I discovered
about making
documentaries is that it
is the opposite of
income producing.
So especially for
something like this.
I mean, I didn't have
any backers or anything.
I just financed the
whole thing myself.
And that was really
one of the reasons
that it took me so long to get
started on it, because I knew
that it was something I
was going to just have
to do on my own,
because I didn't even
know what film I was making
while I was making it.
And when the digital
revolution caught up to a place
where I was actually the
owner of the Canon 5D
that this film was shot
with, then it was like, OK.
The bar to entry is so low
that I can do this thing.
And even if it
comes to nothing, I
was, oh, let's spend a
few thousand dollars.
It won't be that bad.
But now I'm back to
making a little money,
and entertaining a couple
of documentary projects.
Julie?
Yes.
JULIE: Do the people
that own the caves spend
a lot of time
staying in the caves,
or do they rent them out on
Airbnb or anything like that?
JEFFREY KAROFF: You know, I
feel like any of them could.
And I think they'd
do really well.
But part of what drew me
to the subject matter,
besides Ra and his art,
was the peculiar nature
of the people in this
part of the world.
I think it's like-- you know
"Treme," that HBO series?
You could only find those
people in New Orleans.
Well, I think you could
only find these people here
in northern New Mexico.
They're all a peculiar
kind of oddity.
The only difference being
that they're all transplants.
None of them were born there.
So the people were
drawn to this place.
But it does draw a
certain like mind.
And that like mind has a kind
of disdain for-- not disdain,
but they're private.
So none of them really
want to invite the public
through any means at all.
It's actually really
hard to see any
of his caves because of that.
Shel and Liz use their
cave as a guest house.
And they're very generous about
it, so like friends of friends
stay there.
The last time I was
there two weeks ago-- we
were there two or
three weeks ago--
and we walked into
the cave and there
was like a family there
and a Buddhist monk
in full robes sitting on
one of the stoops there.
And I was like, wow.
That looks perfect.
This is a made for you.
And the other people use
them as places to meditate.
And some people have like
music parties in them.
So nobody lives in any
of them as far as I know.
Shel and Liz's
cave, by the way, it
has plumbing and electricity.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
JEFFREY KAROFF: Hi.
AUDIENCE: It seems from the
documentary that for the people
closest to Ra that it was
really difficult over the course
of the years to like emotionally
support him, especially
his wife.
In the time that you worked
with Ra to make this film,
what was your overall
impression of him as a person?
JEFFREY KAROFF: He's very open.
And that was really helpful,
of course, as a filmmaker
that he was so willing
to talk about himself
and not necessarily
in positive--
paint himself in a positive
light all the time.
Definitely what you
see is what you get.
There is no subterfuge there.
He is that guy.
And he's incredibly kind,
incredibly generous person
and was really generous to us.
I mean, down to
the smallest thing
where we had to haul
lots of equipment
up mountainsides many times.
And he's the strongest
guy amongst us by
far even though
he was the oldest.
And he would just pick
up the heaviest thing
and haul it up the
hill every time.
The business with his
wife, it's complicated.
It was complicated, I thought.
Somebody else's relationship,
it's like-- eh, you know?
You know that what.
You kind of wonder.
Sometimes when I watch
the film, I think, well,
why did you get involved
with this guy at all?
But because there's more
to it, there's more to it.
And actually right
after the film
was finished and was showing
and was getting popular,
they separated and
they were talking
about getting a divorce.
And Ra called me and said
this is not your fault.
This really was
coming before this.
And she's gotten a lawyer
and we're getting divorced.
And then two weeks later,
they were back together.
So that's how that's going.
Right.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned the
plumbing and the electricity.
And I noticed other things like
nice wood floors and windows
in some of those caves.
Does Ra do all that, or does
that get contracted out?
Or how does that happen?
JEFFREY KAROFF: He
prepared the walls
for the plumbing
and the electricity
to be put in by grooving
out the pathway.
And there were natural
grains in the sandstone
that he could follow.
But other people did
all of the woodwork
and the electrical
and the plumbing.
And there's a beautiful
door on that cave,
which is just stunning.
But somebody else created that.
And so a lot of really
talented artisans
in that part of
the world, there's
a concentration of
them around Dixon.
Nora?
NORA DVOSIN: I just think it's
worth mentioning the Jeff Bezos
connection because
that one had something
to do with the authorities.
[INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY KAROFF: Yeah,
what Nora's talking about
is that Jeff Bezos runs
this conference every year
called Campfire.
And it is so under the
radar that you can hardly
find it on the
internet at all, which
I didn't think
there was anything
that you couldn't
find through Google.
But it's that kind of a
Ted conference for culture.
And they invite painters,
writers, artists, filmmakers.
And the organizer saw
this film and contacted Ra
and invited him.
And he was really
well-received there.
He did a presentation.
They showed 15 minutes of film.
And Jeff Bezos was
there, and he kind of
made a personal connection
with Bezos, so--
and with a lot of other powerful
people, so at some point,
who knows?
That may be a
force that he draws
upon when he is making his case.
Is that what you meant?
OK.
Thank you guys for coming.
Do you have a question?
Oh, wow.
AUDIENCE: We saw about
the visual images
you talked about, various
helicopter tries or whatever.
But could you describe
your audio process
throughout and what
you had in your mind
for the overall audio
feeling of the project, or--?
JEFFREY KAROFF:
Absolutely haphazard.
I mean, I had-- I
was running sound.
And I've never run sound,
so that should give you
an idea of how well
that was planned.
But I had-- there are
these little audio,
digital audio
recorders now that I
borrowed from my brother-in-law.
And then I borrowed microphones
from friends and stuff
because I don't actually
own any audio gear.
And then sometimes we used a
shotgun on the camera itself.
Sometimes we would do both.
Sometimes we would
end up with no sound
because I forgot to
turn the microphone on.
I have a couple of
scene like that.
Actually, the very
first interview
that I did on the
very first day,
I forgot to start
the audio recorder.
So we had to start over.
I was shocked that the
sound came out so well.
I couldn't figure out why.
AUDIENCE: It all
sounds very good.
JEFFREY KAROFF: Yeah,
it sounds really good.
And I violated
every single rule.
I didn't know how to set levels
or anything, so I don't know.
It scares me to think
like that's probably--
I shouldn't get any
confidence from that at all,
because it'll never
happen that way again.
So yeah, but the guy who
did the music I thought
did a really nice job.
And I was very much hoping that
he would create a soundtrack
that you could
listen to in your car
if you were watching the movie.
And I think he did something
very close to that, so.
All right.
I think we're done.
Thanks, thanks a lot, guys.
Thanks for coming in.
[APPLAUSE]